ah non alors là alors béland non attends
commence et salue on est reparti pour
une vidéo de pure mentalisme
c'est-à-dire à l'ancienne je reçois un
invité que j'aime bien et on va essayer
de le mentaliser aujourd'hui ça va être
ville alma je suis ravi qu'ils soient là
et j'ai préparé quelque chose de spécial
pour lui on va commencer par deux trois
tests et on fera quelque chose de plus
conséquent forcément derrière j'ai aussi
demandé un petit coup de main à mon pad
zapata ceux qui me suivent depuis
longtemps vous l'avez déjà vu deux fois
sur la chaîne mais ça vous en reparlerez
à la fin merci du coup gilles d'avoir
dit oui et d'être venu ça fait très
longtemps en plus quand c'est pas vu oui
c'est vrai sur un petit moment
une des premières fois on s'est vu c'est
quand tu commences et aarau d'été
c'était des travaux mais j'ai pas je
n'ai pas vu mes mais c'est trop cool
parce que là depuis l'étang du tourne à
munger quoi ouais ouais ouais je tourne
dans toute la france les européens la
télé voilà tu dois laisser la place aux
hôtels exactement tu es déjà plus grand
et plus musclé dis pas ça si ici les
gens le voient et joignez vos
commentaires je le vois tu as le cerveau
j'ai les muscles voilà on fait un bon
binôme tu vois je te disais tu m'as de
confirmer ma petite taille je les cuis
le but du jeu c'est d'essayer de faire
de trois experts sur toi pour voir
comment il fonctionne
après d'en faire une un peu plus
complexe bongrain si c'est possible
d'aller aussi loin
et sinon on coupait les gens ne verront
jamais ce passage que je ne dira très
bien c'est ça qui ramenait à faisait
bien son match et youtube tu joues au
casino de taux si tu peux me lubin ouf
tu connais un petit peu de son anneau kg
avec moi trois jetons un de 50 1 200
biens de 10 très bien j'aimerais que tu
les mélanges et que tu le mets ta prête
sur la table face en bas conseil d'accor
gilles quoi d'accord moi pendant ce
temps là je veux juste sortir ce petit
papier que je vais déposer ici
est ce qu'il est dans le cadre mon cher
d'une wii
c'est bien parce que denis contrairement
à louis qui fait des blagues tout le
temps quand on lui pose des questions ça
fait plaisir
oui ou et loïc d'ailleurs c'est le thème
de cette vidéo vous devez chercher où
les c'est plus charlie salotti alors
voici ce qui va se passer de lui a
poussé l'un des jetons au milieu de la
table à temps c'est ton choix
je veux qu'ils prennent le temps passe
et je ne stresse pas oui écoute j'étais
parti sur cela et je me suis dit non
c'est une erreur je vais prendre celui
là tu vois c'est vrai ouais c'est mon
choix puisque tu peut encore changer
d'avis sur celui là non non ça y est je
joue maintenant d'accord ok alors celui
ci tu le prends c'est ton choix tu le
mets dans ta poche
celle ci ça va barder porte sa poche
c'est le futur c'est mon choix n'en
reste plus que deux tout à fait si tout
se passe bien c'est comme si j'avais une
chance sur deux si tout se passe comme
ça dit c'est l'histoire est déjà
terminée tu vas en pouces et un autre au
milieu de la table
d'accord je te laisse deux secondes pour
voir si tu veux changer d'avis ou pas
toujours pas toujours pas vraie chaleur
de moi alors tu le prends dans ta main
et donc le dernier que tu as abandonné
sur la table reste ici très bien tu nous
a laissé sur la table jetons de 50
dollars dans la main tu as quoi j'ai un
jeu tout je le fais je combats je veux
bien 100 dollars ok ce qui veut dire que
dans la poche tu la petite de la regarde
de temps à ma sauce parce que la seule
chose qui est intéressante maintenant
c'est de comparer avec ce que j'espère
est qu'on arrive à faire ensemble à
savoir que tu es le jeu tombe de 10
dollars dans la poche
je trouve ça comme de l'art sur la table
et dans ta main le jeton 200 dollars en
poche il est maintenant messieurs les
leçons biden ne commence pas à m'énerver
parce que ça tu sais c'est vrai ça
s'agace bajeux trois garçons comme chez
moi ça me fait rire tu vois ah oui voir
une question insoluble exactement on va
faire un temps qu'il me takoré
simplement tu mets le jeton dans une de
tes demain et tu t'en les projets
récents avec mes enfants c'est vrai oui
kim et des enfants dans tes mains et non
non dis pas ça va avoir des problèmes d
combien d'enfants
j'ai deux enfants bien sûr
quand c'est là que tu t'en les deux
points vers moi quitte à sortir un peu
du ch en réglant ses preuves et cartes
un petit peu ok si la pièce elle est ici
enfin le jeton s'il est ici je vais te
demander de penser à quelqu'un on va
dire plutôt de musique à la mecque les
jackson ont maintenant si la pièce est
là tu vas pensée einstein d'accord ou à
michael jackson ou einstein et tu ne te
mets dans son état d'esprit
ok je veux mais bien dans le personnage
ouais c'est ça même dans le perso tu vas
ok ça resserre on réfléchit on est
sérieux on plisse les yeux je pense que
tu es sur einstein fait loi oui mais ça
peut être dû au hasard
on va le refaire on va leur faire voir
le jour sans mais ils ont violé ces
partis qu'on va imaginer maintenant une
situation pour pour voir si tu réagis en
fonction des émotions
si la pièce est ici tu a imaginé que tu
es dans une émotion ultra positive tu
viens de gagner au loto et s'ils
allaient y situer dans une émotion hyper
négative qui est en train de vomir
voilà d'accord tu vomis tout ce que tu
peux la tête au dessus des toilettes ok
ok donc un peu dans cet état d'esprit je
ne montrerai en vie d'errance que c'est
dans ce trio alterne c'était puis si tu
vomis me vaut mieux pas dessus
j'ai vraiment pas une once de plaisir
même pas au niveau des sources ija rien
je pense que tu es en train de vomir et
qu'elle est ici oui oui en avant samedi
dernier coup on se chauffe sur le
dernier coup mais on peut pas il va pas
on ne peut pas tricher
enfin une troisième main quelque chose
allait hockey seulement parce que pour
l'instant toutes avaient gardé la même
un verre ça va deux fois ci c'est ici tu
vas imaginé que tu es en train de
piloter un avion
si c'est ici que tu es en train de
piloter une voiture ok et tu vas fermer
les yeux pour le faire et tu imagines
est réellement le faire du pilote un
avion une voiture qui était concentrée
du pour ouvrir les yeux puisque tu étais
très concentré avec les sourcils froncés
je pense que mon nez sur une notion de
vitesse je pense que n'a jamais piloté
vraiment d'avion cette chance et si
c'est le cas du coup tu peux pas
t'imaginer être en pleine vitesse dedans
je pense que tu serais plus en train de
réfléchir à ce qu'il faut la vitesse
pour moi je laisse aussi à la voiture du
coup je pense qu'on était encore là à
dommages et au tây si rapide sainte
était dans l'avion
du coup alors il n'y a pas de twist un
modèle j'avais tout près c'est pas très
grave
ok je préfère avoir des erreurs
maintenant et comprendre pourquoi j'ai
fait l'erreur pour poudlard et là je
veux tu n'es pas comme nous
bon depuis le début de cette vidéo mais
attends je passe pas parce que tu me
sens mal depuis et moi je reste debout
depuis le début de la vidéo je te dis
des mots je fais des choses dans un but
en fait précis en particulier je vais
m'éloigner
on va voir ce que tu vas faire fais moi
confiance je ne peux pas voir et craque
je serai face au mur là bas d'accord qui
es tu peux en témoigner
tu vas prendre ce bloc-notes tu vas
imaginer un dessin un des cinq ans je
dédie un dessin ne fait pas la chapelle
sixtine
non je suis pas de moi un quart par le
simple de schématique un objet ou un
dessin quelque chose qui te vient
spontanément à l'esprit pas forcément le
truc que tu préfère dessiner mais la
chose que tu auras envie de dessiner
maintenant et qui ne serait pas trop
complexes à décider au corps
donc c'est ton choix le plus strict
quand c'est fait tu leur pose ici à
l'envers sur la table et on n'y touchera
plus d'accord parce que la consigne est
bien simple ouais j'ai tout le temps que
tu veux d'accord ça peut être tout on
est bien d'accord peut-être tout même ce
à quoi tu penses maintenant tout ce que
tu veux
j'ai pensé à un truc direct je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai pensé à un simple bah
écoutes je te laisse faire ça je me
recule on va essayer de ne pas faire de
coupes mais si c'est trop long on fera
des coupes et moi je suis si loïc si tu
veux prouver que je regarde le mur ce
sera parfait tu le regardes bien géré à
bella je le regarde bien bien bien là ça
me rappelle quand j'étais petit je
dessine moi pendant ce temps là oui tout
à fait vrai ça me rappelle quand j'étais
petit et je faisais des bêtises c'est
loïc que je sens là juste à cause de moi
c'est ça c'est pas du tout oppressant ce
qui était en train de faire vous avez vu
l'enjeu je vous montre aux parts non non
non non non mais ho caméra non non ils
n'ont pas besoin
personne ne doit voir c'est mon père
c'est la vie d'un bureau à vue alors là
je traite tracy-le-mont automne je vois
rien c'est bon certains agitent eu poker
ça marche
j'ai eu deux trois questions
oui mais pas si c'est la première
question c'est est ce que c'est quelque
chose que tu as déjà dessiné dans ta vie
oui je pense
est ce que en temps normal si on te
demander de faire un dessin c'est le
premier truc que tu dis si mais d'après
toi non est ce que tu sais pourquoi tu
as dessinée ça et pas autre chose en
ligne moi non plus et je sais pas encore
ce que tu as dessinée vrai parce que je
serais très fort
maman je te connais ce faire ton travail
et comme on en fait plus te regarde plus
je me dis est ce que j'ai vraiment
compris comment fonctionne jilal moi je
sais pas alors ouais mais ça j'ai fait
un truc de ouf enfin je me s'élaborer
jamais ça non mais c'est cette fois
c'est simple on regarde bien ces caméras
de cette vidéo qui ne sortira jamais bon
pour l'instant j'ai aucune idée et je
t'avoue que le seuil de pression la
jauge allait à peu près comme ça tu vois
là on va rajouter un truc en post prod
merci lake le dessin on va pas le
laisser là on va l'emmener toujours avec
nous d'accord tu vas l'arraché tu va le
mettre dans sa poche je veux attendre
avant de le faire que l'on soit certain
que ni linger sont ni les cadreurs n'est
personne ici ne puisse voir ce qu'il ya
d'accord tu fais ça a vraiment
complètement il ya que trois ans
l'accord conscience tu me soit dans ta
poche soit dans un sac
moi je te résultant d'une chambre et tu
me dis quand tu es prêt à temps
j'arrache de fonds ajoute bien oui sinon
c'est pas facile d'arracher à 6 et ça va
ça vient au sujet d'un produit les
pointillés sur nous mais ça je plie
correctement
et ça ça va dans la popoche cool je
reviens vers toi ouais c'est bon donc tu
l'arraché qui l'a mis dans une de tes
poches toujours le même et nous on
reviendra là tout à l'heure mais on va
aller un petit peu un extérieur parce
que je le petite balade faire faire ça
tombe bien il a neigé c'est parfait on
va bien s'amuser
on n'est parti que je vous disais
toujours pas en voir et je leur
expliquais s'est déjà fait confiance
par contre si moi j'étais quelqu'un qui
regarde mais quand est-ce que je vais le
voir jouer gilles cyr et de voir où
jouer assez gentil équato alors à paris
et 13 février 27 mars européen à
l'européen et puis après j'ai eu devant
moi comme toute la tournée partout mais
un lien dans la description mais s'ils
ont su si vous êtes à paris à les voir à
l'européen cette salle a les bases d'une
petite du spectacle on peut dire c'est à
écouter un petit fil rouge sur
l'écologie mais attention c'est rigolo
ça reste les volo jamais c'est trop bien
c'est génial de pouvoir apporter ce
thème là dans l'humour
pas mal de gens sensibles là juste là
dernier c'est vrai on en parle de plus
en plus alors tu vois c'est marrant tu
parle d'écologie
parce que dans l'écologie il ya aussi la
récupération tout ce qu'elle a fait de
se resservir du matériel exact dans
paris on peut voir ça par exemple oui on
va terminer avec une dernière chose à
jouer à un jeu tu vas en et ligne 1
d'accord mode chemin fût bois ensuite
deux j'en élimine un écran jusqu'à temps
qu'il ne reste plus qu'un d'accord avec
un bond à gb2 le panneau sur le panneau
bois
voilà ma tasse franchement non je te
laisse avec ces derniers veulent
angeline le chien tu as très bien
ok donc il nous reste que la télé au
final très bien tout ça voilà j'avais
correspond à la télé merci que lloris
était la renier ses saaba entre tout ce
que tu as fait pour nos chers voisins
les téléfilms téléfilm de france 3
huawei est ce que ta tour n'est pas fini
écoute c'est non on sépare c'est une
tradition et mentalisme cette télé il ya
forcément quelque chose qui se peut
s'afficher dessus j'aimerais juste que
tu sors de ton dessin alors non non non
mais je sais pas j'aimerais savoir ce
que dessinait alors là alors mais non
alors je donc là c'est vraiment je sais
certains respectent et des alpilles
[Rires]
ouais je sais je suis très bon
redescends inconduite moi c'est qu'il ya
une émission vraiment qui est diffusée
en ce moment en attendant il ya une
émission qui est diffusée ici non
et quand le détail qui me chiffonne et
cesser de l'art de rue tu sais ça existe
beaucoup et c'est marrant qu'on ait
choisi ça avec exactement un dessin
ressemblant avec un truc de chiffonnade
attend comment c'est possible surtout
que l'art de rue existe et a beaucoup de
mecs comme ça qui font des dessins sur
des choses en gros entre et n'ont rien à
voir on fait avec on descend
tu vois mais alors vraiment strictement
rien à voir
alors que tu aurais pris n'importe quel
objet on note aura illuminé ça avant on
n'avait pas ce à quoi je sais pas si
c'est passé des choses durant toute
cette vidéo il aurait été influencé à d
et ça plutôt qu'autre chose peut-être
que eux ils auront la grance toi c'est
sûr que non tout aucune explication j'ai
un début d'explication d'homme noyau à
donc on va repartir au bureau et au
chaud merci je vous en prie alors petit
retour d'expérience ça ou pas oui quand
j'ai essayé de comprendre sur le trajet
sa part je ne vois pas les discussions
qu'on a eues oui mais bon qu'est ce
qu'ils ferment je vais petite fille tu
l'as dit c'était très gênant mais voilà
non moi j'y reviendrai sur le pourquoi
du comment mais juste après avant
j'aimerais te présenter quelqu'un c'est
la personne qui fait tous ces
magnifiques dessins sa jolie que vous
connaissez que vous avez vu plusieurs
fois sur ma chaîne depuis sa création
vous l'avez vu quand on a fait la vidéo
du 31 décembre 2016 vous l'avez vu aussi
quand il a réussi son passage à
america's got talent c'est monsieur
zapata gens se saluent
bravo monsieur s'apprête à trop cool
bon alors en même temps il ya toutes ces
oeuvres qui a là un petit bout et en
fait l'idée de ce numéro elle m'est
venue grâce à lui parce que tu avais
lancé un projet de dar sur les
encombrants ah oui c'est vrai il ya
quelques temps quelques temps c'est ça
et j'avais trouvé ça trop bad ass et je
vais te lire on peut du coup il s'est
créé le numéro là avec gilles et la tête
tu verras qu'il a eue quand on retourne
la télévision et qui voit ses dessins
alors à voir avec la qualité de ton
dessin c'est plus la surprise mais en
plus c'est ça qui est drôle c'est que
nous évidemment on a parlé tout servant
et forcément c'est pas exactement le
même dessin c'est pas qu'on arrive à
avoir la même chose et je devais même
moi j'ai fait hier quand j'ai retourné
c'était trop cool parce que j'ai eu un
coup de flip aussi quand même mais même
dit
à temps est-ce que lui il a vraiment
fait ça ou pas je savais ce qu'il avait
sur la télé mais parce qu'il est sur le
papier donc beaucoup trop chouette et
encore merci et bravo et ça ça
correspond vraiment aux projets annexes
que tu fais qui me rend ouf mais encore
plus ouf
il ya par exemple ce que tu as fait avec
michael tu as une vidéo sur ta chaîne de
ça ah oui la vidéo de michael jackson
chante ses portraits
ouais ouais alors vous avez un lien au
dessus de nous et un lien dans la
description sur le portrait de michael
jackson fait par zapata je vous en dis
pas plus aller voir ça si je vous dit
quoi que ce soit je joue spoil et merci
arenal vous pouvez rien en même temps
merci beaucoup à toi gym de bercy
toiture et j'avais adoré ça audi passard
et arrête de dire petite fille tout le
temps aller mais bon c'est comme ça ça
j'aime tout le monde allez le voir en
spectacle vous avez le lien avec toutes
les dates et sur son site internet dans
la description également merci les mecs
la question vous vous posez tout c est
ce que ce dessin et fl avance la réponse
est oui maintenant la deuxième question
c'est comment ça se fait que lui et
dessiner ça c'est une vraie question
allait creuser dans les indices de la
vidéo aller chercher pourquoi
à quel moment il a pu avoir cette idée
là et pourquoi il a fait ça si la vidéo
vous a plu n'oubliez surtout pas de la
laïque et vous avez également dans la
description donc les liens pour jil al
mal les liens par zapata les liens pour
ma tournée commence à ce que t'as pas
encore réservé les liens pendant
instagram comment ça se fait que tu aies
pas encore abonné vous avez ici de quoi
vous abonner à la chaîne c'est important
il faut cliquer faut arrêter de regarder
les vidéos sans cliquer là la vidéo de
la semaine dernière une vidéo commentée
par youtube - je vous kiffe
à très bientôt ciao